dass die freiheit über den wolken wohl
grenzenlos sein müssen kann der
belarussische oppositionelle
romankiewicz nur noch als hohn empfinden
nachdem eine diktatur der jedes mittel
recht ist in vom himmel holte machte er
jetzt in einer gefängniszelle in minsk
und hat schlimmes zu befürchten
die empörung im westen ist groß ebenso
die klammheimliche freude in moskau
bange frage ruft die erzwungene landung
der ryanair-maschine nachahmer auf den
plan
luftpiraten aus minsk wer stoppt
lukaschenko jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet ist olga
rhöndorfer sie stammen aus belarus hören
sind wissenschaftlerinnen an der
forschungsstelle osteuropa der
universität in bremen aus brüssel hört
und sieht uns und wir hören und sehen
ihn thomas kutschker korrespondent der
frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung
hier im studio ist alexander rahr
forschungsdirektor des deutsch
russischen forum sie sind auch berater
des russischen energieriesen gazprom in
fragen der europäischen union
und sie haben seinerzeit im jahre 2013
und hans dietrich genscher unterstützt
bei seinen bemühungen um die freilassung
des damaligen russischen regimekritikers
michael rother kosten
schließlich ist unser gast michael harms
geschäftsführer des ost ausschusses der
deutschen wirtschaft frau drin doch
diese gewaltaktion von lukaschenko das
unterstellen wir mal sollte die
opposition in belarus schwächen
ist das gelungen naja erstmal wissen ja
gar nicht was der eigentlichen grund
dafür ist weil es als grund gedacht
wurde also es gibt jetzt auch mehrere
varianten oder mehrere gedanken auch in
expertenkreisen ob das jetzt eine
emotionale entscheidung gewesen ist oder
ob es dann doch solche meinungen gibt es
auch so eine zusammenarbeit zwischen
belarussischen russischen geheimdienste
gekommen ist
wenn es tatsächlich der fall ist dann
wäre eben die folge nicht nur dass die
oppositionskräfte geschwächt werde ich
meinen ist es handelt sich immer noch um
eine person auch wenn diese so wichtige
funktion hatte letztes jahr ist es dann
heutzutage nicht mehr der fall weil die
straßen prozess nicht mehr so
stattfinden
massenhaft zu machen haft nächstes jahr
der fall war sondern dass wir könnte
gewesen sein dass eben dadurch durch
durch diese
aktion die wir jetzt auch aus dem das
beobachten und die ja auch irgendwie
sinn machen die hätte man schon mit
planen können dass die dazu führt dass
daraus dann noch mehr abhängig wird von
russland politisch aber auch
wirtschaftlich also und da sind jetzt
spekulationen die fakten handeln nicht
aber diese meinung ist ja auch also so
eindeutig war es das überhaupt war und
werde als geplant hat der doka dazu
gezwungen hat oder wer in das piraten
hat das müssen wir auch im laufe das nun
vielleicht auch noch mal genauer an
sprechen herr a der russische
außenminister sergej lawrow spricht
davon dass die belarussische regierung
sich in dieser angelegenheit von
vernunft leiten lässt ein
duma-abgeordneter spricht von einer
glanzleistung des geheimdienstes in
minsk und die chefredakteurin von rt die
auch in den deutschen ableger haben ist
ganz neidisch was da denn dass das den
russen noch nicht gelungen ist wenn man
da so alles nebeneinander muss sich
anhört hat moskau doch seine finger im
spiel
jetzt haben sie die extreme ansichten
genannt es ist ja nicht alles so das
brötchen oder jetzt die russische
regierung alles beschloss minister
gewesen
darauf haben sie erwähnt aber der ball
fliegt ja seit monaten mit dem westen im
clinch das ist mehr an die adresse des
westens gedacht was ich eigentlich auch
für falsch halte diese äußerung ich
finde bei lukas schenkel gibt es hier
nichts neues er hat in den letzten
jahren wer weiß russische politik
verfolgt in den letzten 15 jahre immer
gefangenen gemacht
meistens sogar
präsidentschaftskandidaten sagen wir
waren eingesperrt für viele monate ins
gefängnis
der wester protestiert der westen
abgeschrieben nichts ist passiert und er
hat sie irgendwann mal dann doch
rausgelassen milde walten lassen das ist
sein stil und gleichzeitig versucht er
natürlich die patriotisch gesinnten
menschen die die konservativen teilen
der bevölkerung hier hinter sich zu
scharen und gegen den westen auf zu
bringen das ist ein machtspiel dass er
spielt und darauf muss man sich nicht
einstellen aber das kann man auch
analysieren
wie man mit ihm fertig wird jetzt ist
eine ganz andere frage die haben
wahrscheinlich diskutieren leicht wird
es nicht
anhand dieses vorfalls vom sonntag herr
kutschka also die europäische union hat
sich jetzt entschieden überflug und
landerechte für belarussische
fluggesellschaften zu streichen wie
konten von oligarchen von
einflussreichen politikern sollen
gesperrt werden einreiseverbote in die
europäische union wirtschaftssanktionen
gegen wirtschaftsunternehmen aber das
alles hat ja bisher lukaschenko und
seine compagnie nicht besonders
beeindruckt er ist konnte die nicht
beeindrucken weil es ja neue maßnahmen
sind wir hatten bisher ja nur konto
vermögenssperren und einreisesperren was
jetzt beschlossen worden ist ist im
verhältnis dazu einen quantensprung
das betrifft zum einen natürlich die
möglichkeit des fliegens das land wird
de facto vom westen abgeschnitten
dadurch denn das ist ja nicht nur die
europäische union die diese diesen lande
landeverbot und über vom flugverbot
verhängt sondern es werden weitere
staaten dem folgen und das andere aus
meiner sicht noch gewichtigere was am
gestrigen abend entschieden worden ist
sind die gezielten wirtschaftssanktionen
das sind jetzt erstmals die sanktionen
wo es nicht darum geht dass
vermögenswerte eingefroren werden
sondern dass der handel mit produkten
unterbunden wird
und das eröffnet zum ersten mal die
möglichkeit dieses regime dazu treffen
wo sie wirklich weh tut nämlich bei den
staatsunternehmen er aus dessen aus
deren einkünften es sich finanziert das
welche unternehmen das im einzelnen sein
werden müssen die außenminister beraten
und entscheiden
aber es wäre keine überraschung wenn es
sich um große unternehmen der energie
und chemieindustrie handelt die
vereinigten staaten haben ja schon
vorgelegt und mehrere gewichtige
unternehmen auf eine sanktionsliste
gesetzt und das sind die natürlichen
kandidaten hätte ich auf die eu beraten
werden
und jetzt kommt die deutsche wirtschaft
dabei ins spiel wir vermuten mal ganz
stark
thomas gerade gesagt das sind große
betriebe der chemie und der erdöl- oder
der energieindustrie da sind natürlich
unternehmen die sind exportorientiert
sind profitabel
welches interesse hat denn die deutsche
wirtschaft mit einem land weiterhin
geschäfte zu machen dessen führende
politiker jetzt bei staatz terroristen
bezeichnet werden rechtsbrecher mit
denen wir also die deutsche wirtschaft
bisher ja ziemlich gute geschäfte
gemacht haben
naja mit den guten geschäften muss man
relativ sehen belarus ist ein relativ
kleiner wirtschaftspartner von
deutschland es gibt auch keine
nennenswerten deutsche investitionen und
das hängt auch sehr stark mit diesen
politischen rahmenbedingungen zusammen
und das haben wir auch schon deutsche
unternehmen kraftvolle zeichen gesetzt
als zum beispiel die eishockey wm
stattfinden sollte in belarus vom solche
firmen wie skoda vw konzern oder
beiersdorf gesagt sie unterstützen
finanziell diese weltmeisterschaft nicht
aus politischen grünen also die deutsche
wirtschaft hat sich schon da sehr stark
engagiert und wir müssen natürlich bei
wirtschaftssanktionen vor allen dingen
bedenken was wollen wir damit erreichen
wenn wir ein zeichen setzen wollen wenn
wir die freilassung politischer
gefangener wirken wollen sind das
realistische ziele
gefährlich wird es wenn wir versuchen
wollten einen regime change
herbeizuführen
ich glaube das hat auch mit wesentlich
härteren sanktionen und bei solchen
staaten wie iran oder venezuela auch wir
haben gerade gesagt er belarus ist gar
nicht so ein wichtiger handelspartner
aber wir importieren ja trotzdem zum
beispiel aus belarus etwas was ist da
vor allen dingen wichtig das sind erdöl
erdgas energieprodukte düngemittel
glaube ich spielen eine große rolle die
europäische union ja deutschland
importiert vor allen dingen metalle
möbel und holz aber der außenhandel von
belarus wird mehr zu mehr als 50 prozent
von russland bestritten die gesamte
europäische union hat nur einen anteil
von 20 prozent also der hebel ist nicht
allzu stark also was thomas kutschker
gerade genannt hat ist dann zwar sind
zwar wirtschaftssanktionen die werden
aber nach ihrer ansicht wenig bewirken
weil sie ja sehr gut karte schon recht
das wird dem regime wehtun weil es
staatsunternehmen sind in der beziehung
könnten diese funktion schon relativ
gezielt eingesetzt werden freude war wir
haben den namen roman rotasia bisher
kaum vernommen in der öffentlichkeit
hier zumindest im westen wenn es um die
proteste in belarus gegen das sind uns
vor allem zwei frauen nahmen im
gedächtnis svitlana diakovska und maria
callas nico war
welche rolle spielt denn pro tasse
witsch in dieser ganzen opposition in
dieser oppositionsbewegung dass man ihn
sozusagen mit einem piratenakt vom
himmel holt wie ist seine wie seine
stellung in der russischen opposition zu
bewerten so gut wie gesagt momentan ist
die rolle nicht mehr so hoch her ist
noch der fall wir es noch letztes jahr
der fall war deswegen hat es mich schon
überrascht inwieweit die maßnahmen
überhaupt angemessen sind wenn wir uns
gedanken machen welche innovationen man
von ihnen bekommt wir haben ja auch
gesehen wenn video gerade was zugegeben
das sieht aber nicht gesund aus
höchstwahrscheinlich bruder schon von
den geheimen listen sicherheitsbehörden
geschlagen
der war wichtig allerdings nicht als
allein es also als person sondern in
einer gruppe mit anderen menschen die in
telegramm kanal nicht da oder nächster
wie es hier drüben durch erklärte
gegründet hat und dann auch war auch
lange redakteur lässt es ja und was
besonders an diesem kanal das ist
wirklich dass dadurch die aufrufe dazu
polen aus den strassen zu präsentieren
tatsächlich durch die sozialen medien
verbreitet oder und das ist auch zum
ersten mal passiert ist in der barroso
schon geschichte oder protest geschichte
dass die menschen im aufgerollt und auch
das gemacht um sich dort gesammelt haben
also wo ist das sagen im grunde wurde
durch diesen kanal
dadurch war das natürlich schon ein
wichtiges instrument und das war auch
genug schon gefährlich weil das nicht
beeinflussen konnte weil die ganzen
menschen aus und lassen und über
telegramm kann
der russe mobilisiert hatten wie gesagt
damals ich sage ja damals weil wir
selbst spätestens ende november dezember
diese massenaktionen protestaktion bei
brust nicht mehr
visuell nicht mehr beobachten die
proteststimmung ist immer noch stark
allerdings protestierende menschen nicht
mehr weil die gefahr eines politischen
engagement heutzutage viel viel höher
ist als es mal früher also um es bisher
der fall war
die menschen haben ihre proteste nicht
dadurch verloren liegt dürfen jetzt aber
nicht sie die handys einfach angst und
sie können ja auch um es gibt ab
todesstrafe muss man auch nicht
vergessen ich hoffe das wird nicht
passieren aber da wird als terrorist
bezeichnet von der russischen staat also
ist schon ernsthaft allerdings würde ich
ihnen jetzt nicht als opposition oder
die opposition bewegung bezeichnet es
gibt nicht die eine opposition
mindestens bei den wahlen letztes jahr
gab es mehrere treffen mehrere
gruppierungen die mobilisierung der
menschen beigetragen haben in dem fall
es ist jetzt nicht die hauptfigur die
opposition gut aber es ist ja jetzt so
dass er dass er die protestbewegung
haben gerade ihr abgeebbt ist das also
die gefahr für lukaschenko nicht mehr so
groß ist freut mich vorhin gesagt man
weiß nicht genau was eine geplante
geheimdienstaktion oder was vielleicht
sogar emotional also so eine art
kurzschlussreaktion von lukas schinko
gerade einer den mann der jetzt nicht so
eine ganz große rolle gespielt hatte man
gar nicht auf dem radarschirm hatte
gleichzeitig hat man die protestbewegung
unter kontrolle die macht im moment
nicht auf warum dann diese aktion
ehrlich gesagt verstehe ich das nicht
vielleicht weil es günstig war das
flugzeug über dem britischen luftraum zu
haben freut sich ein oscar hat glaube
ich einige tage vorher genau den
gleichen weg benutzt die hätte man ja
auch schon zur landung zwingen können
die ja glaube ich auch die etwas
wichtigere ist die ja auch in litauen im
exil lebt waren wir jetzt und nicht so
bewusst aber lukaschenka könnte
natürlich so eine schnelle
kurzschlussreaktion natürlich gehabt
haben gesagt haben den hole ich jetzt
vom himmel runter und
also jetzt ziemlich mit dem westen
weiter auseinander
das problem ist nur dass er auch putin
in also ich glaube nicht dass ist eine
gemeinsame geheimdienst operation
gewesen ist das braucht russland in
dieser zeit nicht kurz vor dem treffen
mit biden und da wo die beziehung mit
dem westen sich allmählich vielleicht in
bestimmten sachen abrüstungsfragen
verbessern
ich habe auch keine beweise dazu aber
ich denke dass lukas schenkel hier
alleine gehandelt hat das problem jetzt
sein wenn jetzt sanktionen auch wie die
engländer es fordern auf russland
übertragen werden und dann der luftraum
über ostern geschlossen wird oder die
ganzen transitwege das muss man sich
vorstellen nach asien sie laufen über
weiß über das kleine weißrussland aber
dann über russland das wird uns uns auch
sehr teuer zu stehen bekommen nicht nur
den russen und den weißrussen weil wir
dann andere transitrouten viel viel
teurer suchen müssen um unsere produkte
nach asien zu bringen es gibt ja auch
die landverbindung über weiß was dann
wohl ast autos fahren das ist auch sehr
wichtig also man man muss da wirklich
genau überlegen wie man hier weht um
sich dann selbst als als europäer nicht
in den ins bein schießen dann kommt nur
zivilgesellschaft dazu wenn wir jetzt
weiter und absperren von der von der von
der übrigen welt dann können die
menschen die gerade fahren müssen nach
westen nicht mehr zu uns kommen weil die
flugzeuge nicht mehr gehen und über die
grenze man heute nicht so leicht drüber
kommen kann
das muss man auch mal bedenken also ich
hoffe dass das die sache nicht zu viel
zu zu zu eskalieren
dass lukaschenko nicht noch mehr mist
baut und dass wir hier vielleicht dass
es eine wunschvorstellung zu einer
lösung kommen die dann auf größere
sanktionen vielleicht ja auch größere
aktionen wird da nicht nach nicht mal
zwei minuten dann kommen wir auch gleich
noch hält der hat ja in brüssel relativ
schnell reagiert ungewöhnlich schnell
ungewöhnlich einig ist man sich denn in
brüssel eigentlich klar was da genau
passiert ist das ist ja schon etwas
komisch dieser flug wenn man da mal
diese route verfolgt der gegner ganze
strecke über das gebiet von belarus erst
kurz vor der litauischen grenze kamen
dann diese angebliche bombendrohung
das flugzeug war viel näher an vilnius
einem zielort der hauptstadt von litauen
als
an minsk muss sozusagen litauisches
gebiet dann noch umfliegen das sei
irgendwie sehr kurios und chaotisch aus
ist da noch von einem kampfflugzeug
einer mit 29 begleitet worden kann man
sich da in brüssel einen reim drauf
machen wie das passiert ist dabei hatten
ja nur noch wenige kilometer gefehlt bis
zur litauischen und gebiet wie das da
gekommen ist dass es mit diesem ergebnis
dann kam das einer drin denen unbedingt
lukaschenka haben wollte aber auch die
art und weise wie diese erzwungene
landung zustande gekommen ist die ist
doch ziemlich kurios nicht nur kurios
sondern brandgefährlich das ist ja nicht
auszudenken was alles in einer solchen
situation hätte passieren können die es
so noch nicht gegeben hat offenbar hat
dieses kampfflugzeug den piloten
regelrecht zur landung gezwungen
durch ein bestimmtes manöver und ich
gehe stark davon aus dass dieser pilot
alle regeln befolgt hat die für die
zivile luftfahrt gelten nur eine regel
gilt natürlich immer und das ist es
dürfe hier keine eine zwangs akte
vorgenommen werden ohne eine ein anders
ohne einen grund diesem grund also die
angebliche bombendrohung hat es nicht
gegeben die es fingiert gewesen wie man
erstens daran sieht dass das flugzeug ja
viel schneller in vilnius gewesen und
zweitens ist nur darum ging personen zu
verhaften im übrigen sind ja dann auch
einige passagiere in linz geblieben was
der bemerkenswert ist und sicher noch
gegenstand weiterer untersuchungen das
ist übrigens die datei der auch in
brüssel bis jetzt nicht geklärt ist wir
haben die bundeskanzlerin vor hinter
nachgefragt was war die rolle russlands
gibt ja den verdacht dass hier agenten
mitgeholfen haben mitgewirkt haben an
dieser aktion aus meiner sicht
keineswegs unplausibel wer das gerade
dargestellt hat und der europäische rat
hatte dazu keine gesicherten
informationen sagt die kannst du dann
das gesagt aber sie hat auch gesagt
würde mir putin das nächste mal darüber
reden also wenn sie das so formuliert
dann wird sie wohl wissen dass es keinen
dass es da durchaus redebedarf gibt und
es diese harte harsche reaktion der
europäischen union ist natürlich auch zu
erklären mit der reaktion aus russland
das war ein versuch die opposition
einzuschüchtern
die reaktion in moskau das verständnis
für lukaschenko das werk erklären all
das weckt doch den verdacht dass auch
putin geneigt sein könnte
auf diese weise oppositionspolitiker
einzuschüchtern festzunehmen auch da
gibt es ja eine menge leute auch noch
aus dem umfeld von alexei navalny die
nur noch aus dem exil heraus agieren
können und deswegen war das unbedingt
notwendig diese harte reaktion denn sie
ist auch das signal an putin wenn du
etwas ähnliches unternimmt dann passiert
das was er geschrieben gegeben auch
beschrieben hat dann wirst du die
gleichen folgen tragen müssen und das
wäre für russland natürlich
wirtschaftlich verkehren auf russland
kommen wir gleich noch haben es die
haben sie gerade gehört beziehungsweise
alle noch in erinnerung den letzten
sommer die proteste die ja über wochen
und monate in linz gegen da stand sehr
spitz auf knopf nach der
präsidentschaftswahl die ja nach all dem
was wir wissen
gefälscht war das wahlergebnis was das
eigentlich für die deutsche wirtschaft
in das jetzt bedeutet oder bedeutet es
jetzt hat sich durch diese proteste
durch diese latente unzufriedenheit das
kann ja immer wieder aufbrechen hat sich
für die wirtschaft da sehr viel
verändert in eine gute
handelsbeziehungen unter
unternehmensaktivitäten brauchen ja auch
ein stabiles umfeld also die
wirtschaftliche lage in belarus ist gar
nicht so schlecht wenn man sich die
objektiven zahlen ansieht die wirtschaft
ist letztes jahr nur sehr gering
zurückgegangen das hat auch damit zu tun
dass lukaschenko jacke ohne ignoriert
wird und es gab keinen doktor
keine maßnahmen allerdings das
entscheidende für die wirtschaft ist
berechenbarkeit verlässlichkeit und die
sehr sehr stark untergraben worden das
war auch früher nicht brillant aber
jetzt ist das eine ziemliche katastrophe
also es wird nach meiner meinung nach
keine investitionen geben werden sich
sehr zurückhaltend
auch josef jung hatte gesagt die 3
milliarden bleiben erst mal auf eis
die drei milliarden waren auch vorher
schon auf eis ist ein bisschen eine
milchmädchenrechnung dass es das was
eingestellt wurde in der östlichen
partnerschaft für belarus da ist ja
belarus immer noch offiziell mitglied
aber eigentlich seit den protesten seit
beginn dieser politischen krise lagen
die auf weiß das ist also jetzt völlig
unrealistisch da von diesem geld könnte
auch russland einspringen
diese lücken zu füllen naja russland ich
bin auch skeptisch ob wirklich
lukaschenko ein so guter verbündeter von
roses erstens hat er immer wieder auch
die antirussische karte gespielt auch
politisch auch vor den wahlen
es ist wirtschaftlich ein minusgeschäft
für putin und wie gesagt er ist
unberechenbar auch für wladimir putin
und ich will noch mal sagen als die
proteste in belarus waren letzten sommer
und lukas schenkel die zusammen knüppeln
ließ haben die leute in cabarets bislang
friedlich demonstriert da ist in
russland nichts passiert also ich würde
schon diese gleichung nicht so machen
und da ist muss man schon etwas anders
gut wenn putin jetzt keine helle freude
an lukaschenko hat dann ist ja die frage
warum er ihn trotzdem unterstützt könnte
es denn sein dass sie ja gerade schon
angedeutet dass die demokratiebewegung
die da in weißrussland belarus wie es
jetzt heißt da entstanden ist dass die
angst bei putin steht dass das
möglicherweise aus russland überspringen
könnte abwerten könnte man hat ja noch
die meisten proteste in der ukraine im
gedächtnis die sind noch nicht so lange
her die auch zu massiven konflikten dann
geführt haben auch außenpolitisch ist
das etwas was putin fürchtet eine
demokratiebewegung in einem nachbarland
die dann nach russland zurück
reflektiert ja vielleicht aber ich
glaube die demonstration für neuwahlen
wären ja dann fühlt
wichtiger gewesen für die russen und
außer der großen demonstration im januar
das in den letzten wochen ja nichts
gegeben die bewegung gibt es hier kaum
mehr auf der straße
sie haben mich gefragt was für putin
wichtig ist bei lukaschenka der
unionsstaat der unionsstaat als putin an
die macht gekommen ist vor 20 jahren
hatte lukaschenko beim ersten treffen
klar gesagt mein ziel ist dass sich
russland und weißrussland vereinigen
willst du da willst du nicht nur
kaschiert gott gesagt nein wir wollen so
werde ihnen bleiben und dann fängt das
spiel an über 20 jahre hin und her aber
natürlich wartet der putin bis
lukaschenko oder weißrussland wie
wirklich so eine reife frucht ihm in den
schoß fällt weil er mit dem westen dann
überhaupt nicht mehr kann weil die
weißes schild überhaupt nicht mehr in
die eu fahren wird können weil die nato
an der grenze stehen wird zu
weißrussland und dann wird lukas
schenkel nichts anderes übrig bleiben
als nach russland zu gehen vielleicht
eine art canossagang weil er sich
natürlich auch entschuldigen muss für
viele manöver in den letzten jahren
gegen russland durchgeführt hat so sehe
ich jedenfalls die interessen russlands
fördern darüber wenn diese wenn das
tatsächlich auf eine union hinauslaufen
sollte zwischen belarus und russland
also belarus quasi der föderation der
russischen föderation beitritt wenn
lukaschenko eine art kostgänger
zumindest ökonomisch von putin ist kann
man das sagen dass belarus eigentlich
schon faktisch bestandteil der
russischen föderation ist nur noch
staatsrechtlich ein souveräner staat
also erstmal er nicht was heißt klar
also diese unabhängigkeit von russland
gab es ja schon vor den protesten wie
gesagt sowohl wirtschaftlich als auch
politisch aber auch kulturell also die
ganzen soft power instrumente die hat
hier nicht nur die oder usa auf russland
manche nennen das autokratie förderung
was auch immer also sprachliche
kulturelle und historische ist einfach
da und die wird auch nicht schwinden
wenn die demokratischen kräften los und
war einmal gewinnen werden das müssen ja
auch im kopf behalten
eine andere frage ist für mich wenn
bilderberger aussprechen dann heißt es
ja nicht lukaschenka ist nicht bloß in
belarus ist nicht sogar schon klar da
ist an der macht sie sollen aber nochmal
uns gedanken machen ob die bevölkerung
so was akzeptieren würde wir sprechen
hier nicht über irgendeinen region oder
im staat sondern schon über ein land das
das seit 1991 unabhängig ist damals nach
dem zerfall der sowjetunion gab es
diesen wunsch nach unabhängigkeit den
bussen nicht so hoch und der war nicht
so stark und die menschen haben
anteilig auch deswegen für lukaschenka
abgestimmt ja damals hat er wirklich
dieser 80 prozent der stimmen bekommen
was wir heute sind beide sind natürlich
andere generationen da sind die menschen
die jetzt protestiert hatten
sie werden nicht akzeptieren dass
belarus sind wir ein teil von von der
russischen föderation wird das könnte
natürlich versucht werden wie gesagt
aber welche gesellschaftliche folgen es
haben wird und würsten in den
öffentlichen meinungen dargestellt wird
das wird irgendwie gar nicht diskutiert
ist überrascht mich jetzt so ein
bisschen als ob wir ein land ohne
menschen hätten also die umfragen zeigen
auch nicht dass der wunsch da als die
russen sich schon in russland sehen
thomas gutschker wer das was wir jetzt
erlebt haben auf dem eu-gipfel sozusagen
nur ein kleines vorspiel sie haben sie
auch gerade schon angedeutet alexandra
auch dass der eigentliche das
eigentliche problem mit russland
auftreten könnte wenn tatsächlich die eu
sich jetzt bei dem nächsten eu-gipfel
das hat jetzt mit den vorfällen minsk er
gar nichts zu tun noch mal mit russland
beschäftigen wolle der beziehung zu
russland die ins aktionen dem ziemlich
zerrütteten verhältnis was niemanden so
richtig froh macht wo die eu staaten ja
auch sich nicht einig sind anders als
bei belarus was droht denn da an gefahr
in den beziehungen zu russland dass sich
diese situation noch mehr verschlechtert
noch mehr verschärft die beziehungen
noch
ja nicht nur schlecht dass man
möglicherweise in ihren konsequenzen
auch gefährlicher werden also zunächst
mal muss man sagen dass nach der
diagnose der europäischen union oder
ihres außen macht hatten die beziehungen
sich an einem tiefpunkt befinden und
alles was wir seit dem letzten sommer
erlebt haben spricht ja auch wände ist
ist seit der verhaftung von alexei in
der beine oder seit dem gift nervengas
anschlag auf ihn im august zu einer
kompletten verschlechterungen auch in
allen bereichen gekommen
russland hat mit einer vielzahl von dann
darauf folgenden provokationen dazu
beigetragen dass auch eine echte
sanktions spirale in gang gesetzt worden
ist und der versuch von borel den er
unternommen hat anfang februar die
beziehungen zu öffnen mal auszuloten in
moskau was ist denn möglich welche
kooperationsbereitschaft gibt es dort
ist ja damit beantwortet worden dass
russland während seines besuchs
westliche europäische diplomaten
darunter eine bank wohnen deutschen
diplomaten ausgewiesen hat und damit
letztlich der europäischen union aber
auch den großen mitgliedstaaten die tür
gewiesen hat also zwischen diagnose in
brüssel
jedenfalls aus der sicht bereits in ich
glaube ja trifft da ein den den punkt
und trifft auch den nerv
diese zwischen diagnose lautet russland
verabschiedet sich von den westlichen
und den europäischen werten es hat angst
vor demokratie und menschenrechten und
diese angst bewegung führt eben zu einem
extrem harten durchgreifen gegen die
opposition und verschmälert den bereich
dessen wo man zusammenarbeiten kann
natürlich muss es weiter zusammenarbeit
geben zum beispiel gegenüber dem iran da
ist die eu wie russland einer der
garantie staaten auch in klimaschutz und
in einigen anderen feldern aber schon in
der energiepolitik haben wir ja gesehen
was wie sich die situation in den
letzten jahren verändert hat deutschland
steht da ziemlich allein und planiert
damit nord stream 2 und ich glaube wenn
eine solche entscheidung heute noch mal
zu treffen wäre würde sie mit sicherheit
nicht so getroffen werden wie seinerzeit
das ja der vorwurf alexandra dass
russland trotz gegenteiliger
beteuerungen kein wirkliches interesse
an einer normalisierung zum westen hat
der widerspreche ich weil es ist
schwierig jetzt so widersprechen aber
wissen sie wenn ich mit russischen
verantwortlichen entscheidungsträgern
treffen und ich komme gerade aus kazan
zurück wo einige solche leute dabei
waren auf einer konferenz dann heißt es
immer wir wollen mit der europäischen
union reden aber über gemeinsame
interessen
was russlands nicht mehr machen will
unser putin und labor ist auch nicht
mehr tun wollen ist ein gespräch über
menschenrechte und demokratie zu führen
über werte transfer und der westen die
europäische union und auch die
amerikaner sagen auch immer wieder wir
wollen mit den russen eine partnerschaft
modern haben eine
modernisierungspartnerschaft modernen
verfolgen wenn die russen eben diese
werte mit uns teilen oder wenn es in
diese richtung gehen und das ist der
unterschied die russen sagen nein wir
gehen nicht richtung westliche werte wir
haben unsere eigenen werte ist eine
andere diskussion was das für werte sind
aber das ist die crux der großen wunder
denn das ist eigentlich auch die die
strategie gegenüber china die frage wird
sein wer stärker ist wer wird das ist
ein kräftemessen china und russland auf
der einen seite werden natürlich uns
zwingen nicht überwertet zu reden
sondern mental essen und vielleicht
werden sie auch siegen oder der west mit
stark genug sein durchzusetzen dass
seine agenda menschenrechte
rechtsstaatlichkeit good governance und
all das andere doch wie vor 10 oder 20
jahren
die haupt agenda der diplomatie sein
wird
wir haben sie haben es vorhin genannt
was wir aus belarus beziehen holz export
möbel ein bisschen jugend im mittel wenn
es um russland geht reden hier von
anderen dimensionen was ich jetzt da
andeutet dass es möglicherweise die
situation verschärft dass sanktionen
weiter verschärft werden möglicherweise
wie in den 1970 er jahre 1980 er jahre
nach dem abschluss des jumbo-jets über
sachalin 1983 zum beispiel wenn sich
diese entwicklung weiter verschärft dann
geht das auch die wirtschaft etwas etwas
befürchten sie da gerade im umgang in
den beziehungen zu russland zu ihm zwei
ist ein aspekt es gibt aber auch viele
andere bereiche die die beziehungen die
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen zu russland
betreffen die deutsche wirtschaft auch
wenn man dann nach china guckt wo
ähnliche diskussionen stattfinden da
ganz schweren zeiten entgegen
ja natürlich ich sehe das aber auch in
einem größeren zusammenhang ich würde
das nicht unbedingt am fall belarus
festmachen hier stimme ich an rad zu ich
sehe keinen unmittelbaren zusammenhang
mit russland die grundsätzliche frage
auch für die deutsche wirtschaft ist wie
gehen wir wirtschaftspolitisch mit
autoritären system um die sich bewusst
für einen anderen weg als der westen
entschieden hat das ist nicht nur
russland das ist china das ist die
türkei das sind andere länder und hier
müssen wir sehen wie wir diesen spagat
zwischen werten und interessen aushalten
wie wir den gestalten und sie haben ja
die 70er jahre erwähnt und was ich da
glaube ich ganz gut anbietet wäre
vielleicht eine rückkehr zu einem neu
interpretierten system der koexistenz
das war ja das schlag wurden der
siebzigerjahre einmal anzuerkennen zu
sagen wir haben bestimmte bereiche wo
wir uns unterscheiden wo wir bewusst
verschiedene wege gehen aber dann in
gemeinsamer verantwortung solche themen
anzugehen die global wichtig sind wie
zum beispiel den klimawandel
das könnte vielleicht ein weg sein wie
wir auch mit russland umgehen können das
heißt also wir könnten durchaus könnte
es passieren dass sich die
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen oder ganz
neu ausrichten
möglicherweise auch schwächer werden man
kann sich kaum vorstellen dass die
deutsche exportwirtschaft auf den handel
mit china oder russland also vor allen
dingen mit china großenteils verzichten
kann exakt und das was die amerikaner
uns vorschlagen also ein deka blicken
ein komplettes abkommen der
wirtschaftssysteme ist für uns nicht
machbar aus meiner sicht da ist die
deutsche wirtschaft von china vor allem
auch viel zu sehr abhängig
ich glaube dass eine solche sie können
es selektives engagement in oder eben
eine neue art der koexistenz der
produktive weg wäre ich glaube
umweltschutz klimaschutz ist die neuen
spannungs politik da war was erwartet
denn die belarussische zivilgesellschaft
jetzt in dieser situation das land ist
plötzlich im fokus
zumindestens der westlichen politik
wegen der erzwungenen landung der
ryanair-maschine was erwarten die die
menschen in belarus jetzt da sie haben
gesagt aber sie fühlt sich irgendwie
übergangen so als spielmasse für
russland die am liebsten möchten dass
belarus in die russische föderation
eintritt was erwarten die menschen da
ich glaube für die menschen dort für die
organisation des zivilgesellschaftlichen
sation oder unabhängige medien und uns
so weiter so all das weiß vom staat als
potenziell gefährlich oder nicht loyal
gesehen werden kann
bei den hat sich jetzt nicht so viel
seit dem wochenende verwendet weil die
repressionswelle gebrachten überwachen
die ja schon seit einiger zeit seit
oktober 2020 spätestens das wird
erwartet er nicht auch das was hier ja
klassisch zur demokratieförderung oder
auch schon humanitäre hilfe gehört das
heißt finanzielle förderung oder
moderation mit der gesellschaft oder
einfach aufnahme von migranten und
menschen die das land verlassen wollen
oder versuchen es zu verlassen ist eine
andere frage
natürlich wie sie es machen jetzt wenn
es dann tatsächlich dazu kommen dass er
leider nicht mehr in die eu fliegen wird
glauben sie dass hier noch
demokratiebewegung nochmal fuß fassen
kann in biel los also das was im letzten
was wir im nächsten sommer gesehen haben
oder wird er jetzt erst mal eine zeit
der
der stagnation auch der resignation
eintreten
also wir haben jetzt eine sehr starke
reaktions werner vom staat also jetzt
wird quasi alles was sind wir nicht
unbedingt politisch aktive sondern
irgendwie nicht staatlich aktiv ist
friedlich unterdrückt und dann würde ich
schon dem widersprechen was er da gesagt
hat dass es nichts neues ist ist das ist
wirklich fast alles neu also was die
gesellschaftliche mobilisierung angeht
aber auch was die natur des phishings
klar dass es immer noch autokratie aber
auch autokratien können unterschiedlich
sein so stark reis noch nie in belarus
so beispiellose rezession haben wir in
dem maße noch nicht gesehen und es ist
jetzt immer noch eine autokratie der
minderheit das heißt lukaschenka hat
nicht mehr die mehrheit das hat er jetzt
in unfalls noch wichtiger ist für mich
wenn wir jetzt noch mal zurück zu
gesellschaft kommen die menschen hand
gesehen
zum ersten mal gelang dieses gefühl
bekommen bekommen
wir sind die mehrheit das war nicht
immer so es gab auch unabhängige
umfragen die immer gezeigt haben
lukaschenka hatte immer 50plus stimmen
natürlich nicht die 80 prozent die ganze
zeit aber über die mehrheit ist er immer
gekommen und dieses war dieses mal war
es angeblich nicht der fall und dieses
gefühl wird auch nicht in bi zu gehen ja
die menschen können jetzt nicht drücken
weil sie angst haben aber sie haben
jetzt noch hoffnung bekommt wie haben
wir eine andere art von motivation eine
mögliche ein möglicher grund für die
heftige reaktion der europäischen union
ist ja wie heute ein kollege auch von
uns geschrieben hat der dass das eine
art präzedenzfall ist was da am sonntag
über weißrussland über belarus passiert
ist dass da möglicherweise staaten wie
russland türkei kasachstan china genau
auf die reaktion der europäer achten es
war ja ein flugzeug aus einem eu-land
aus irland rein er ist das auch etwas
was die europäer in brüssel umtreibt
dass möglicherweise diese form staatlich
sanktionierter luft piraterie schule
machen könnte
absolut und das erklärt warum man so
schnell und so entschlossen gehandelt
hat man muss sich ja mal vorstellen
dieses thema weißrussland belarus stand
ja bis gestern überhaupt nicht auf der
tagesordnung des treffens der staats-
und regierungschefs als die erste
sanktions welle im sommer angelaufen ist
hat es mehr als zwei monate gedauert bis
man sich auf ein paket mit ungefähr 30
personen geeinigt hat gestern hat es 24
stunden gedauert seit diesem vorfall bis
die europäische union reagiert hat das
ist nur durch zu erklären durch diesen
wirklich präsident losen bevor fall und
die sorge dass hier eine norm in der
internationalen luftfahrt die die zivile
luftfahrt schützt wenn sie einmal
gebrochen ist auch von anderen gebrochen
werden kann wenn ich noch etwas zu sagen
darf zu der frage wo dazu der debatte um
die interessen
die europäische union ist
selbstverständlich bereit und willens
mit russland über gemeinsame interessen
zu reden aber die signale die von putin
ausgesendet werden seit dem letzten
sommer sind eben nicht signale die auf
eine gemeinsame interessenpolitik zielen
sondern die norm einreißen die nicht nur
westliche norm sind sondern normen des
internationalen systems nochmal der
anschlag schon auf sergej skripal und
dann auch auf den oppositionspolitiker
dabei nie mit einem nervengas sarin
verstoß gegen die chemiewaffenkonvention
das ist ein absolut gravierender vorgang
und wenn putin solche schritte
unternimmt heißt es dass er etwas
einreist
wahrscheinlich liegt es auch daran dass
sie ja selbst innerlich im inneren
innenpolitisch unter hohem druck steht
und eben nicht mehr die außenpolitischen
folgen bedenkt
da sich im übrigen eine parallele auch
zu belarussen leider müssen wir
feststellen dass ebensolche regime die
keine oder nicht mehr ausreichend
unterstützung genießen zu einer gefahr
werden für die nachbarstaaten und damit
auch für die europäische union das noch
radikalere kräfte in russland die gerne
noch viel mehr auf konfrontation gehen
denn hier ist die werden auch gleich
argumentieren und sagen ja rechtsbruch
hat stattgefunden
bitteschön auf der krim und in asien
aber angefangen hat der westen in
jugoslawien und mit dieser maschine ist
es ja auch schauen sich die russischen
medien heute abend das ist kein
primitiver butterbrot es muss einfach
nur sagt vor sieben jahren wurde von den
amerikanern damals über österreich das
flugzeug des bolivianischen präsidenten
vom himmel geholt und war aber sagt halt
ein bisschen anders gewesen
er war also eher und snowden schien in
dieser maschine zu sein war nicht aber
gelandet hat er weil ich die oder
gewichte landen in wien derweil italien
spanien portugal und frankreich den
überflug der sänger haben der den hätte
man den hätte man den hätte man nicht
weiterführen können im übrigen haben
sich diese länder hinten nach bei
morales entschuldigt bei dem damaligen
bolivianischen präsidenten und audi auch
mann aus dem flugzeug heraus verhaftet
also das war ja aber wenn der boden dort
gewesen wäre er verhaftet worden
gut aber wie gesagt aber der sagt er
warendorf anders aber die parallelen
sind ja immer zahm und es gibt eine
konvention über die internationale
zivile luftfahrt chicago konvention und
die maschine von herrn morales war ein
staatliches flugzeug das wie
militärische flugzeuge anderen regeln
unterliegt man darf das nicht in einen
topf werfen
diese strategie wird denn ostern
verfolgt aber wir müssen hier ganz klar
die unterschiede sehen
haben es wenn man sich jetzt die
situation in osteuropa anzieht die sehr
verworren ist das ist ja nicht nur
russland das ist nicht nur belarus das
ist auch die ukraine
das sind konflikte zwischen
osteuropäischen staaten und russland
polen das ist sozusagen historisch
langer zeit schon entstanden es gibt
auch zwischen tschechien und russland
wegen spionage und sabotage akten jede
menge vorwürfe die situation scheint
verworren zu sein in richtig verfahren
was bedeutet das für die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung aus sicht der der deutschen
wirtschaft die ja mit diesen ländern
ganz unterschiedlichen handel treibt das
ist ein absatzmarkt er seinen
rohstoffmarkt in der umgekehrten
richtung
das müsste sie ja eigentlich ziemlich
nachdenklich und auch pessimistisch
machen nein das macht mich
merkwürdigerweise nicht pessimistisch
und ich erkläre ihnen auch warum weil
sich zeigt dass die staaten die den weg
nach europa gefunden haben die
rechtsstaatlich und marktwirtschaftlich
organisiert sind nämlich die visegrad 4
auch wirtschaftlich die erfolgreichsten
sind also die vier mittelosteuropäischen
staaten mit denen handeln will mehr als
mit china das sind ökonomischer
erfolgsgeschichten und weißrussland was
ein autoritärer staates vielleicht sogar
eine diktatur ist eben überhaupt nicht
erfolgreich sondern ist sehr schlecht
und russland was doch irgendwo
dazwischen ist tut für eigentlich gut
daran diese reform auch zu etablieren
also in der beziehung zeigt sich schon
dass die rezepte die wir immer
propagieren nicht nur werte sind sondern
dass die auch zum erfolg und unseren
interessen dient oktober ist denn so
dass lukas schenkel nicht nach ein
diktator ist sondern dass er auch
wirtschaftlich ökonomisch ein elefant
ist dass er versagt hat gerade was die
die wirtschaftliche situation in einem
land angeht das ja auch auf
wirtschaftliche stabilität aus ist die
menschen wollen auch dort in wohlstand
und gut leben
na ja dann würde ich noch keinen fall
bezeichnen sondern werde er auch nicht
seit über 26 jahren
er machte schon flug daran was er macht
das muss man zugeben eine andere frage
ist es wie gesagt es hat sich jetzt so
so logisch drastisch
als ich früher sehr gerne als
präsidenten dargestellt hat und es gab
tatsächlich einer zeit da es ist großen
mehreren jahren in die die waren ja
nicht reich aber es ging menschen immer
besser das hat er ja eher mit russland
zu tun also damit dass da die alle
produkte also auslosung günstig gekauft
wurde und dann ölprodukte indio weiter
verkauft wurden und daran war es
tatsächlich auch aber den menschen ging
es irgendwie besser und besser und
einige haben schon geglaubt dass so ein
modell so ein prophetisches modell
wirtschaftsmodell auch und wie
erfolgreich sein könnte ich glaube der
präsident auch selbst daran geglaubt
sehr lange gezeigt hat uns gezeigt dass
es jetzt nicht mehr der fall wissen die
menschen haben es auch bemerkt und
dieses modell ja gut es hat jetzt über
26 jahren weiter existiert aber es hat
jetzt null chancen auf erfolg und das
verständiger außenpolitisch intensität
leben gut eine ziemlich verfahrene
situation
ich bedanke mich bei all katrin dort war
bei thomas kutschker aus brüssel
bei michael haben sind bei alexander
rahr liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde sehnsucht nach urlaub was
ist möglich in europa dann sitzt
angebotener hier an diesem tisch jetzt
folgt phoenix der tag mit constantia
platz zum thema unter anderem die
pressekonferenz nach dem eu-gipfel in
brüssel wir bleiben also beim thema
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]